[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
we talk about whatever we want and today
there's no joke we talk about whatever
we want to spend that time oh that's
true well don't we meet Jesse do what
jess is the Joe expert in authority
right and it's it's things more coming
and she defined her invitation she
heavily declined it heavily really
looked and guys a little bit a little
bit more than you bless it masked and
sweet boys when we were in Bahamas I
thought you looked whiter contrast the
people around everyone's whacker than me
from the snow no Iceman you see his new
nobody calls one of those things that
just stopped yeah it's like do you call
it because we couldn't figure it out no
they call him Iceman and they call him
miracle man I've never heard who they
are I think you spent the most time with
him right yeah I do I do
hey Nicky usually called me Iceman on
our podcast I was just saying [ __ ] they
don't tell you know I asked why you
weren't calling yourself Iceman well I
like he normally do caught up that I
should be called ice Mantha yeah so how
was the Bahamas perfect
it was y'all missed out we invited
everybody let me just tell you we begged
they did and we gave them a year in
advance cuz we were gonna go last year
and then they were like oh it's too soon
and so we're like okay next year and
then they then they bail that door every
year this is just you two we go
somewhere every year guess what it was
way more perfect that was really cute he
was because we were catching up
yesterday and then he was like oh it's
the coolest thing just traveling with
your best friend don't you know and I
was like yeah it's [ __ ] can't say
that I said something sexist
yeah like a true massage thing you said
something about but I remember good for
something like that right yeah yeah I'm
there I just know that I'm Eric Griffin
just thought I was the biggest [ __ ]
[ __ ] by the way to Tenakee like he
thought the whole time he was here my
game was that I don't really get women
and [ __ ] like they complain too much and
stuff and he was just trying to teach me
he's so sweet but you know what's good
those when he was saying those things I
was actually learning so I was learning
a lot I'm like cool what was so fun
about it is that he had really great
answer so I didn't even feel like I had
to have input I was just asking more
questions on behalf of people who like
me yeah do do is a perfect spot there
because it had everything you could
possibly want if you like tropical
vacations so it has love trouble the
best beaches I've ever seen like the
whitest cyan water the like clearest
scientists and then they had like the
bali different pools okay so oh you made
a choose between it's way better but
Bali I will say has way more culture or
at least the places that we stayed in
Bali versus the place that we stayed in
the Bahamas Louie the stage we stay in
the tourist deist part of culture is you
can get a hot dog
culture if we left the freaking reality
your area was like a resort like a
resort
this is they want you to stay here and
spend money here it keeps the culture
out which I like right yeah like a true
American if you take a toll bridge to
get back in so like they literally don't
want you to really don't want you
leaving yeah what kind of food is it cuz
I'm a big food guy so hamburgers because
local hog right Dixie mm-hmm they did
have like really good fresh-cut seafood
they had a Nobu there we had
reservations thing we bailed on them
because we were like nah we're to trash
I don't want to be hungry and only to
leave a restaurant hungry that's
broke yeah right thank you thought
you're gonna be leaving they're hungry
order that [ __ ] Jose Andres those are
please you're starving afterward that's
our tradition exactly
well it's the witch's food yeah and the
novelty of experience they're selling
you the air margaritas but still you
should've just gone to the bar and left
one of the coolest parts is they had a
lazy river that went around the entire
place cuz they have 141 acres of water
park no I'm not sponsored I'm just a fan
so yeah like you you all the slides they
go into the lazy river and then the lazy
river takes you to the front of all the
slides and then if you want to get off
and go get a drink you can then get back
in the lazy river and if you want to get
off and go to the beach for a little bit
you can then you go back a lazy river
and if you want to go up so one of the
other pools you just get off and go and
then you get back the lazy river
the only thing they need to work on a
workshop maybe is to have like an area
in the lazy river we can throw the
bathroom oh it's called the lazy river
no that's insane you want to be lazy and
go in the room the bathroom is called
the lazy river oh I understand no I
unfortunately for certain kinds of
restrooms
there's so many kids they're already in
the nice pools
how do you differentiate now I'm trying
to think if I was ever in front of you
like probably I'm not while you were in
there was I behind you like in the beach
definitely we're in the beach I
definitely like there's a current
there's the waves okay you flora did
your butt hole no I claim my butt hole
in the beach Wow so you know like
sometimes like you have an itchy butt
and you're like I know I didn't wipe
your butt you know you wiped it good you
know hard way and then some
I don't know yeah
and so I'm just like oh man well I can't
wait till we get to the beach because
then I'll be able to I figured I was
going to make me look like less stressed
that's true that's my dog he'll always
do that so if I'm ever in the water and
my hands are above the water I'm taking
garbage bin recycling bin yeah yeah
cream you weren't here last week yeah
when we talked about M&M I know I have
so much catching up to do to hear your
opinions uh well I feel like I don't
even need to have opinions on it because
there's so many videos I've been made
already about it and also I think in
kinda is kind of irrelevant so I don't
even need like he doesn't need to dis
him back and also I like just there's so
much there's so much of that dis track
that was so bad it wasn't good that it's
like I only eminem is a legend dude Nick
Cannon is from the guy from drumline
brother give me a [ __ ] break
call some Elvis [ __ ] at one point I was
like goddamn and I can't believe I
missed this love the whole Suge Knight
thing was really weird tears it was
really long I was just like oh we're
just gonna listen to this whole message
good night like spent he's like one
prison phone call I need a really big
favor
tried on the same level it's not even
close so like for me if I was Eminem
I wouldn't even respond now my god just
not even on the scene it's like Eminem
responding to a guy who talks [ __ ] on
him at a gas station
yeah like he is gonna respond because I
feel like he tweeted yeah and I in the
tweet got more views it's a funky
district then McKenna's district got
more likes than yeah more likes the new
views of the district yeah so there's
that yeah can we talk about real quick
why they call me the miracle man why do
they call you the miracle man how do i
Spencer
last night we wore at the danger boys
premiered thank ya he was wearing two
chains and then like you're just trying
to pretend to be better than Eminem and
then she was like where's Marshall I
don't Iceman advice on this one I'm
gonna lie
no so uh but aren't you the miracle man
yeah that's what they call me okay okay
so we were going to Vegas
and we were basically gonna be late
[ __ ] super [ __ ] ultimately [ __ ]
those old news in the know hola nikki is
in we didn't get to tell us where
Nikki's in the car panicking because
there was a [ __ ] nerdy traffic jam of
the area this is when he slammed in her
face against the coffee before the
insole so we're about to be [ __ ] we're
like 20 minutes away from the airport
and our flight is like what 45 minutes
away from takeoff yes so basically we're
[ __ ] and Nikki's like looking up but
the flight so she's on the phone with
the airline and Baylor Elliott oh yeah
and everything was on track until they
[ __ ] closed some roads down during
Thanksgiving weekend like why so the
whole time for you Nikki's panicking
Nikki starts like you know breathing
hard and like crying and [ __ ] laying on
the side panic attack okay right get on
the floor of the car and while you're
doing stories over not even kidding I'm
sitting there just chills [ __ ] right
because I know so is this the ice matter
the cool or the miracle you know I'm
taking care of it with Delta no that's
not what it's because I knew it was all
gonna work out just fine and I said that
I said we're gonna make it you'll see
mommy I see yep that's a miracle it's
the miracle he said okay so the and we
so we are [ __ ] driver who had been
the slowest [ __ ] no all of a
sudden in their maximum power job turns
into the biggest [ __ ] about numbers
he goes in the opposite lane oh my god
is the wrong way hardly know
every one off against traffic he cut yes
and he cuts holy are you having a panic
attack exactly that's what I'm waiting
for
know this story okay well he slammed
[ __ ] I had if everybody cut everyone
off everyone's [ __ ] double burning
out the window yeah more double words on
my life I would like to [ __ ] la
musical right so then we get to the
airport we're still kind of [ __ ] but
we're over there right
I'm snickies running I'm walking the
whole time why am i walking because
she's like she's having a panic attack
having
dick face never travels she's having a
bad exact how can she run why don't I
live just going off of what you said no
but right she's that's the same guys as
he travels at his best friend any was it
okay so then so then we get there we're
[ __ ]
all of a sudden out of nowhere a guy
walks up to us from a console a crime a
company and he's like hey I can take you
guys the front of the line right now
right now oh oh okay everything happened
instantaneously we walked in the front
of security line we get right through we
get to an airline Miki's running even to
the airline then I'm walking because we
caught you $100 to do that no it didn't
no it's a promotional deal 30-day free
trial know that do you a plus for that
guy though so we were like we could use
it twice but it was [ __ ] to cancel but
it hasn't been 30 days yes however does
not have a story went to the airport we
was sitting at the airline not even
kidding you the second we sit down now
boarding in a bit of a [ __ ] play the
[ __ ] miracle man that's why they come
thank you wait who called you that I
never sell truth is always
is it a chicken or egg situation because
our supremely nice uber driver that was
such a dear and when it driving even a
mile of just call our [ __ ] I forget
what his name was yeah so he was only
like oh you're gonna miss her plane and
tell I started having a [ __ ] panic
attack and he's like there was a crazy
[ __ ] get into the airport and so I made
that miracle happen secondly if I didn't
run to the [ __ ] a terminal check-in
area then we wouldn't have run into the
clear guy you dumbass that's true yeah
true by the time you caught up to me or
by what the miracle man is the reason
why he ran into is cuz you're in my
chill ass orbit which is why people have
a lot of confusion between call me
miracle man or call me I said you guys
can live in your world okay three names
I don't know which ones I should choose
let us know in the comment section what
the [ __ ] you just jump [ __ ] yeah every
time since we've been together every
time you thought we're [ __ ] we're not
gonna make the airport or you thought
that I was [ __ ] would make at the
airport I mean it [ __ ] a lot of my lip
got busted open like I don't know where
this miracle man [ __ ] is coming through
because like miracle man [ __ ] me up
like where's the hill but guess what you
got flipped into a nightstand and guess
what it all worked out it seemed like
things we're not gonna go so well and
then Oh debatable accent maybe your face
looks garbage
it's better now I turn to the blinking
guy meme just now you may hit me so hard
that mean what's the part of your face
cause bleeding this part this like lip
lick my lip part yeah it's fine now but
just a scar forever a permanent scar
there's not it'll go away where yes I
think I see it and I'm so far I'm
sitting so far from her and I could see
that I like it because it's kind of sexy
it it's kind of lend a hand
Hamilton me it reminds me of like
what's-his-face Phoenix Joaquin Phoenix
oh yeah he's got a sick one ya know what
I was going for but you know guess
that's my new brand yeah [ __ ] the
miracle man don't you make at the
airport every time we didn't get
pregnant so where's that miracle [ __ ]
how much have you guys been trying that
was our first month of like about having
unprotected sex during ovulation yeah
it's the one it wasn't one no keeping
track girl we're synched up yeah but I
we got nervous that last time Oh
cancelled what's crazy what's crazy it's
like it's not as easy as you think it is
yeah or like I don't know when you even
you hear about like some other friends
that are younger it's like people always
have like the people that aren't
supposed to be parents yeah
so easy and then they're not stressed
about it yeah that's cuz they like you
want it so obviously you can't have it
and I did and I got a busted ass
drinking do I think that Steve drinks
too many monsters and so that way I
don't think that these these sterile
[Laughter]
we got new tape lower thirds right here
give me this [ __ ] because I had one time
and the other time got interrupted by
the [ __ ] nightstand did you fight the
night well did you rebus once before the
night yeah but I wanted to go again
so the night that wasn't in the well but
two would have been confirmed should
have been faster than like you already
busted once an you busted the night
before they're tired they like retractor
vacuum there's Louie we had a long night
before okay so yeah yeah so where the
[ __ ] do they go no they were tired
coming
oh they swam back out I honestly think
that you're so warm that they're like
hot so worm and then just like laid down
oh really
you fell asleep instead of doing their
job what a weird I hope it was still
like breathing in retrospect so do i
yeah oh [ __ ] you know yeah whatever we
want
whyever under vacuum let it marinate
yeah hold my legs yeah we didn't do that
you did that
[Laughter]
oh you like show up to the fertility
clinic if I go just step us through like
what you guys are doing Steve lays back
and lets it Mary oh we talked too much
drinking tea as many years ago that they
kept trying to get pregnant but they
weren't actually having sex
oh pretty in the butt all right that's
breeding ground it's like a story in
China I kept busting messages but and
then her but he convinced her it was her
but your mom I think that's really
conversation went in that episode to
consume your mom told you that babies
came out of your butt oh yeah yeah yeah
cuz I think she she felt embarrassed
talking about vagina to me oh so she
just said oh yeah you came out of my my
butt
do you think the guy in China convinced
her that her [ __ ] was her [ __ ]
that's pretty genius genius so she's
like freaked out every time she's like
yeah
[Music]
[Music]